that I'm sorry that wasn't my point my  point is my Point's not on like the  attention that you're getting from them  my point is that like  I we were talking about like whether or  not  um  the body count thing yeah yeah like the  body count thing like whether or not a  man who has no bodies is attractive like  biologically whether I would be more  attracted to him or not like I like I  would I would love to have like pursued  a relationship where we were both like  waiting until marriage it's just like  it's just not  it's it's just not common there aren't a  lot of men there there are it's one out  of three like trust me if you want a  virgin go down to Tesco  [Music]  talk to your your locals one previous  number it's like it's like it's like  okay Walgreens let's go to Walgreens  that's hilarious go to Walgreens look at  look at the man behind the counter about  five six five seven that's so funny yeah